-Oh, my gosh!
I am so happy to see you guys.
I had an unbelievable adventure
last night.
-What did you do?
-I went out on the town.
I painted the town r-r-r-ed,
as Doja Cat would say.
I went out to a -- John Sykes
invited me to the
Rock & Roll Hall of Fame
pre-show, like, a dinner.
And Michele Anthony
from Universal
and Monte Lipman --
they invited me to this dinner.
No press.
They used to do these dinners,
I guess, before the --
And they stopped doing them.
-Yeah.
-So they did it.
They brought it back last night.
We went to a place
called Gabriel's
on Upper West Side.
And you walk in, it was just --
It was all the nominees
and all these great people.
I walked in, I saw --
Immediately, I saw
Patty Smyth and John McEnroe.
That was cool.
And so I went over.
They introduced me to
Bernie Taupin,
who is Elton John's -- Yeah, he
wrote all Elton John's things.
So I was talking to him.
He was funny, making jokes.
Then there was
The Spinners were there.
And I went up to The Spinners.
What were The Spinners' jams?
-Oh, man.
"Then Came You,"
"I'll Be Around."
-Oh, no, the one I like is...
♪ Could it be I'm falling
in love with you, baby? ♪
♪ Could it be I'm fall-- ♪
I should get onstage
with The Spinners.
-You should spin, yeah.
-I should join The Spinners.
But I went up to them
and hopefully I wasn't
bothering them.
But I did.
I went up and I said...
♪ Could it be... ♪
I sang it to them.
But we talked about
doo-wop and stuff.
And then I started singing
doo-wop with The Spinners.
-Oh.
-Then I went over.
Oh, the night gets crazier.
And I go over and I'm talking
to my friend Michele
and I feel a little tap
on my shoulder,
and it's the coolest ever.
Sheryl Crow in the house.
She says hi to me.
I go -- I love Sheryl Crow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love her.
She walks me into this room.
Peter Frampton is there.
I say hi to Peter Frampton.
H.E.R. was there.
I sat down with Steve Miller,
and we talked
about "SCTV" for an hour.
And I laughed with Steve Miller
for an hour.
We talked about
the Schmenge Brothers?
-Yeah. Cabbage rolls and coffee.
-Schmenge Brothers.
-Yeah.
-Talking to Steve Miller
about John Candy.
-Come on.
-I know. It was making me laugh.
And then DJ Kool Herc was there,
who was the father --
-He invented hip-hop.
-Invented hip-hop, yeah.
-Basically had two turntables
and played two of the same song,
but just elongated the breaks.
-The break, yeah.
-And, so, anyways, he was there.
I talked to him.
He was unbelievable.
And then, on my way out,
I see Andrew Ridgeley.
-From Wham!?
-From Wham! Yeah.
And I go, "Yo,
I have to tell you,
you came off so cool
in that new documentary."
He was awesome. I got to
tell -- It was unbelievable.
And then I left
and I couldn't get a cab.
So I was just kind of
standing around.
I just started walking.
Then this cab pulls over and was
like, "What are you doing, man?"
I go -- And it was John McEnroe.
And I go, "I don't have a car."
And he goes,
"Oh, come to my apartment
and then call a car
from my place."
So I went to Johnny Mac's
apartment, and we hung out.
And I got a car from there.
It was amazing.
But for the first time ever,
this is the Rock & Roll
Hall of Fame,
is being live-streamed
tomorrow night,
8:00 p.m., on Disney+.
So this is the first time
they've ever done this.
You watch it. It's just gonna --
It's gonna go.
That's a party. Tomorrow night.
But Kate Bush, Missy Elliott,
Willie Nelson,
Rage Against the Machine,
The Spinners, Sheryl Crow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is all happening.
Unbelievable. That is
tomorrow night, Disney+.
Fantastic. And thanks
for everyone for inviting me
to that secret dinner.
That was cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]